en la medida que pasan los días y ya
cuando los norteamericanos han
abandonado el aeropuerto de kabul la
crisis humanitaria especialmente de las
personas que buscan refugio en los
países vecinos empieza a hacerse mayor
en los últimos días miles y miles de
personas han llegado a varias embajadas
europeas en teherán especialmente la
alemana donde esta mañana una multitud
se agolpaba las puertas donde no se
recibe a nadie entre ellos hay miles de
afganos tanto refugiados como migrantes
que habitan en este país más de 4
millones de afganos habitan en irán
muchos de ellos han llegado buscando una
mejora económica pero también se han
visto afectados debido a la crisis
económica que afronta este país y muchos
quieren emigrar hacia europa pero
también hemos visto a muchísimos
afganos que han cruzado en los últimos
días la frontera con irán muchos de
ellos lo han hecho de manera ilegal
usando la vía de estos contrabando de
estos de este contrabando de personas
que llegan en casi en condiciones
infrahumanas nos decían que pasan en
carros que llevan muchas veces hasta
1820 personas caminan y caminan por
horas en carreteras desérticas sin tomar
ni agua y muchos de ellos vienen con
niños pero todos tratan de buscar
refugio pues muchos de ellos pertenecían
a las fuerzas armadas y a la policía y
también hemos visto muchas mujeres solas
que buscaban protección en este país y
luego viajar hacia europa